is it just Anakin Dominick Cruz doing
like a yeah yeah just two man crew god
Hannah go home I think everywhere kids
go home to like embrace is his gig man
he loves it I don't think he was in
China for for Zhang Wei Lee did he catch
him or was he going for a takedown it's
hard to tell I was hard to tell there um
how about way Lee Jong or Zhang Wei Lee
like a chick yeah
the one who just [ __ ] up starts on
Josh I didn't see the fight was it legit
allahö look 40 seconds so crazy striker
a lot killer manage the [ __ ] is she 20
20 and 1 she's like 20 in a row she's a
monster
she caught her with a right hand hurt
her and then finished Hiroshi and one Fc
I don't she's being [ __ ] up somewhere
but she uh maybe maybe I gotta be honest
I've never heard of her till then I was
it going on Josh you're gonna steamroll
oh really
no I've seen her fight I don't know I'll
solve women's fighting that deep she's
[ __ ] I don't know you need to change
that didn't you get did people get mad
at you we're talking [ __ ] about the
strawweight division I don't know I'm
sure I don't care I have a fight show
and then if it's kind of a fight it's
like the lifestyle show not like others
fight this weekend I know she is
Entourage for the win that's that's our
cover